Hi, good afternoon.
Um, just a reminder for you to wear your
headsets on and uh please
give me a thumbs up if you can hear me.
OK, awesome. Great. Thanks.
Um, welcome to CMP 307,
which is our breakout session today
on how Graviton enables
the best price performance for your AWS workloads.
I'm Sudhi Rahman, director of product management
at DC2 for Core Compute Products.
And co-presenting with me today are Ali
Saidi, VP and Distinguished
Engineer at AWS,
as well as our guest speaker for today, Thibaud Delor,
principal engineer from Atlassian.
Super excited today to bring you a um
a deep agenda where we're gonna talk more about
our Graviton journey,
customer stories.
We're gonna dive deeper into our latest Graviton 5
chip that we just announced a few hours
ago today.
Um, Thibo is gonna walk through Atlassian's
journey and the key practices and
the best learnings from that,
and we will cap this off with
some of the knowledge base and the best practices
for you to get started on your graviton journey as well.
So with that, let's just dive right into it.
At AWS we've been building custom
silicon
for more than a decade.
And this includes custom chips across multiple
different areas
spanning, for example, our nitro
chips
where which are part of the overall AWS Nitro
system
that allows us to offload dedicated
functions such as storage and networking
to custom silicon.
And allows us to enhance performance,
security, and maximize resource efficiency.
We're also building custom chips um to
accelerate machine learning applications,
so these are chips such as inferentia and ranium.
And then we have powerful and efficient
core compute infrastructure
through graviton-based servers.
So if we turn our attention to graviton,
why gravion?
So two key value proposition
areas for our customers. First thing,
it delivers the best price performance for
a broad array of workloads in Amazon EC2.
So really helping you run your
applications faster and lowering costs
overall. And
secondly, we find that a lot of our customers
have goals towards lowering their overall carbon
footprint and improving sustainability.
And graviton with its energy efficiency
benefits
allows our customers to make significant progress
towards those goals.
So when viewed in aggregate today, we have more than 90,000
AWS customers
that are drawing on Graviton.
And these range from some of the
hottest startups all the way to very
well established Fortune 500
enterprises.
And our goal is to enable a
deep and a broad portfolio of graviton
instance types so that our customers
can choose the right instance for the right workload.
And today we have over 300 graviton-based
instance types that are available globally at scale
in over 38 AWS regions.
And here's a look at our graviton journey over
the last seven years.
So when the first chip came out in 2018,
this was more about getting the overall software
ecosystem up and running
on the AM 64 architecture.
And then 1 year later, Graviton 2 came out
and it opened up a whole array of general
purpose applications
to be able to run on Graviton.
And our focus
with each generation
has been to improve the performance,
push the boundaries on the capabilities as well as
the energy efficiency benefits that we can deliver
with each iteration of the graviton chip.
Along with also improving capabilities
for certain specific workloads.
So with Graviton 3
that delivered a 25% higher performance
per core over Gravidon 2.
We also
put in optimizations in there for certain computer
optimized workloads
such as video encoding,
CPU-based machine learning, as well as high performance
computing. With
the graviton 4 chip that came two years later.
That built in 50% more cores
per chip
and that opened up the whole array of scale up workloads
for our customers. So
think of large databases, analytics,
all of those scale scale up workloads that could
benefit from
higher compute and more instances
uh per per core.
Which then brings us to the latest and greatest chip that
we just announced earlier this morning,
the Gravidon 5 chip,
which is the most powerful and the most
energy efficient chip that we've built thus far.
So we're going to talk more about that shortly.
So just going back to the theme of enabling a broad
and a deep portfolio
for our customers across all their use cases,
here is an example of our Gravidon 4 portfolio
today. What you can see is
that there are options available from
384 gigs of memory all the way up to 3
terabytes of memory
for workloads that span compute general purpose and
memory optimized use cases.
And if you have workloads that benefit from fast
access to local instant storage,
so NVME attached instance types,
we have a bunch of those as well,
and some of them support a whopping 120
terabytes of local SSDs using
Amazon SSDs.
And we realized customers have a diversity of workloads,
so there are workloads that are more sensitive to
IO performance,
so things like more networking or more EBS,
and we have instances for those applications
as well. Now
if you look at the Graviton servers,
in addition to a lot of the hardware components
that go into these servers.
AWS has also integrated and
has full ownership
of the firmware and the software that goes along
with it. So this means
that it's not just a graviton host CPUs in
the server,
but it's also our nitrocards
for EBS for ENA.
And the Amazon SSDs and the software
that goes along with these Nitro cards and the Nitro Hypervisor,
all of these come together,
and that allows us to tailor these servers
to deliver the best performance
in the Amazon environment.
Now a most common customer question that comes
up in several of my customer conversations is,
what kind of workloads can run on Gravidon?
And the answer here is really, really simple,
is that it's a wide range
of general purpose workloads that we see customers
using Gravidon for.
So everything that ranges from a web
application to a containerized microservice,
all the way through large databases, analytics,
CPU based inference,
as well as electronic design automation.
Now with over 90,000 AWS customers using
Gravidon,
here is an example of some of the customer types
that are using Graviton today, and what
you can see here is that customers across every
geo and every vertical
are drawing on the graviton benefits.
So, if you look at the top 100
EC2 customers,
every single one of them today is drawing on Graviton.
And if you expand that cohort to the top 1000
EC2 customers,
more than 98% of them are
drawing on Graviton today.
And overall we've been hearing great feedback
from customers on the cost and the performance
improvements they're seeing, and here are some examples.
With ClickH, they saw a 25 to 30%
improvement on average across multiple credit
types,
and in some cases up to 76%
improvement in performance.
FreshWorks, when they ran their Ruby on Rails
applications and Java applications pretty seamlessly,
saw a 23% improvement in average response
time. And with Cora, when
they migrated from Graviton 3 to 4,
they saw about a 20% improvement in
query serving times.
And it's not just about price performance.
We're seeing a lot of customers
benefit from the sustainability benefits of Graviton
as well.
And here are some examples.
With Snowflake,
they saw a 57% reduction
in the carbon emissions per Snowflake virtual
warehouse credit
after moving to Graviton,
while also enabling about 10%
faster performance on average.
And you can see a similar storyline with Adobe
and Jay Frog here as well,
where they were able to reduce their carbon footprint by up
to 60%.
No conversation today is complete without talking about
machine learning, given the AIML era that
we are in. And we are seeing
a lot of customers also deploy CPU-based
machine learning applications on graviton-based
instance types.
An example here is Mobbi Eye.
When they enabled their change detection
system to run on graviton instances,
they saw up to a 2x improvement in overall
performance.
And you also have an example of Sprinkler where they ran
their mixed inference and search workloads
and achieved up to a 30% reduction
along with up to a 30% cost savings.
And it's not just external customers,
but we at Amazon are also
employing Graviton at scale across a wide
array of managed services.
So what you see here is that
a wide set of Amazon database
services, as well as some services like MSK
have a pretty significant deployment
of Graviton service today.
For example, with Amazon Redshift services, more
than 90% of the current deployment is
on Graviton.
And outside AWS and even on the Amazon.com
side, we've been using Graviton
for some mission critical events like Prime Day,
where this year more than 40% of compute
of Prime Day was powered by Graviton.
So with that background, I will turn it over to
Ali Saidi to tell us more about the
latest ship that we just launched today.
Thank you, Sudhir.
So let's talk a bit about Graviton 5.
With Graviton 5, we are going
beyond Moore's Law and doubling the number
of cores that we have um
in our, in our chip from graviton 4 to graviton
5.
each of these cores
uh is doing about 25% higher
performance
and
you know we've built Graviton 5 in
a 3 nanometer process.
Let's zoom into the pieces that make up
this processor.
We've talked a while about big workloads and
how micro benchmarks
are very different
from big workloads and how we like to design for
big workloads where we're not talking about
um you know small loops but really all the
code and complexity of a real
application like a database.
This needs things like bigger branch predictors
so you can process more instructions a cycle,
um, and you know
with Graviton 5 we've adopted
the Neoverse V3 core.
It's an AM V9.2 core. It's
got bigger branch predictors. It's got more advanced prefectures,
and it's generally a higher performing core.
Then we coupled that with our cash hierarchy.
Uh, optimizing uh a chip is
a complex optimization problem of figuring out where are
you going to put cash.
You'd love to put it all as close to the processor as possible,
but physics gets in the way.
And so um
you know the L2 cache is great. When we went from graviton
3 to graviton 4, we doubled the size of
the L2 cache to 2 megabytes.
We've kept that here,
but we've increased the size of the L3 cache.
Um, we've made it 5.3x
bigger than it was in graviton
4. It's now 192 megabytes.
And in total between the L2, the L3,
and the L1 caches we have around 600
megabytes
of cash.
With Graviton we've really tried to lead with DDR.
This has meant working with DDRAM vendors.
Graviton 2 was the first system
where we pushed to DR 43,200.
Graviton 3 was the first system we had with
DDR 5.
And
with, um, Graviton 5
we're working with DRAM vendors to,
to get all the way up to DDR 8800.
We've also reduced the GRM access latency
in graviton down to less than 100 nanoseconds.
That's about 15% lower than
it was before.
Grabtone 5 also is the first system
in CPU
in our fleet to support PCIE
Gen 6
with around half a terabyte a second
of bioconnectivity.
Now we've taken 96 or 192
cores and, and put them
in one ship.
And in doing that we've reduced
pneumo latency
that we had by about 33%.
We've increased bandwidth
um substantially,
but we're not getting rid of pneuma even though it's in one socket.
We've decided to keep
Pneuma and offer two pneuma regions
to reduce memory latency.
Uh, so that the cache and the DM
controllers are closer to your course.
So with all these pieces we have
the ingredients for our 9th generation of
EC2 instances.
The M9G instance that we're previewing today,
um, has industry leading performance up to 25%
better than Graviton 4.
It's the most energy efficient CPU we built,
provides the best price performance in EC2,
and provides us the same scale
up capabilities that we had before.
Now I'm gonna spend a few minutes talking a
bit about security.
There are many things that a hypervisor has to do. It has to
do scheduling, it has to do resource allocation, it has to
do IO. And when virtualization
started, it was really about packing many of your own workloads
together. And we've talked over the years
about how nitro is different.
With nitro, we've moved networking, storage
and management
onto dedicated silicon.
And nitro has many jobs to do, but the most important
one is keeping customers isolated,
isolated from each other and isolated from us.
With the nitro system,
um, we have no operator access, and we
enforce that with mechanisms, not with
policies.
With our nitro cards, we've been raising
the bar and security with Graviton.
With Graviton 2, we introduced DRM encryption.
With Graviton 4, we introduced PCIE encryption.
We've taken the attestation that we had
from our nitro cards and graviton 4
and moved it to also be
allow us to attest
the the CPU, the, the host CPUs
that we have.
With Grabs on 5,
We're going one step further.
The the nitro hypervisor is purpose built for one
job, and it's an amazing hypervisor,
but we constantly ask ourselves,
can we raise the bar?
So coupled with graviton, we've been building another layer
of technology
to increase the transparency in our virtualization stack
that we call the nitro isolation engine.
It sits between the graviton CPU and the nitro hypervisor.
So what is it?
It's really compartmentalizing
the most critical elements of interactions
with instant memory, devices, and access
control. There are two
interesting things about it.
The first is it's written in rust,
and so rust gives you a lot of memory
safety and memory and concurrency properties, which
are really cool.
But the second one
is that formal verification was
a part of this code base from the start.
We started building this,
we had software engineers working
in tandem with some of our applied scientists
in our automated reasoning group.
Um, to formally specify
what the, how the, how the software would work
and, and what it could and
couldn't do. So
what's formal verification? Let's take
a simple function like this.
It's got 3 inputs,
um,
and, you know, how can you be sure that it always
works?
Well, the easy way is you can try
some test cases. You can try all 0s, you can try
some 1s, you can try maxims.
Um,
but you can't exhaustively test it,
even if you say you had.
A CPU that could do a billion
tests a second and you had a billion CPUs,
you'd still need more time than the age of the universe
to exhaustively test this function.
So formal verification lets you mathematically prove
that the function specification, adding numbers,
matches the implementation.
It's really about the application of mathematical
logic and reasoning
and the application of that to software systems.
So you have a formal specification, and that
formal specification
tells you how it operates.
Um, what it can do, what it must do, what
it must never do
for all possible inputs in all reachable
states. For
example, in the nitro case of the nitro isolation engine,
it can create and manage VMs.
It must preserve guest confidentiality
and integrity, and it must never do things like null
pointer to references or buffer overflows
for all possible inputs
in all possible states.
So we've been proving
functions, the core features of the
nitro isolation engine in the VM
life cycle
and showing that,
It has memory safety even in the places where
you have unsafe rust code.
There aren't any runtime errors. There aren't unreachable panics
or unwraps on none.
There's
no logical errors that the specification
and the implementation match,
and then there's no unauthorized information leakage that we're
we have confidentiality
and integrity.
And we're going to expand this
to to uh
more and more.
Uh, parts of the system,
every M9G instance is gonna have this enabled
by default.
We're gonna be engaging customers on the formal verification
aspects of this
in the, the coming months.
OK, so let's talk a little bit about designing and building
graviton.
One of the things that
the engineers who are working on Graviton
are most excited about is actually
using um a current
generation of our processors to design the next
generation. And when we started this,
this, um, that wasn't a possibility,
but over the years we've seen EDA tool vendors
begin to support EDA flows on
graviton.
And
today, Siemenscaliber
is excited to announce support of
Caliber on our Graviton systems.
Caliber is the industry standard sign-off tool
used by a majority of design companies.
It's one of the most critical tools to run fast because it's
coming at the end of the design process, and you're trying to
iteratively solve all your issues and
get to the point that you can start manufacturing design.
And not only did Graviton
4 show 20% higher perth and 30%
cost reductions compared to the other instances
that Siemens tested, they also
saw an additional 30%
performance boost
when looking at Graviton 5.
So it's super exciting
to see caliber
um support coming to Graviton.
For over a decade since the inception of Annapurna Labs,
Synopsis and AWS have collaborated to enable
AWS's custom silicon development,
and so we're also excited
to announce that Synopsis is expanding support
for their EDA tools on Graviton
like VCS, Prime Time, and Fusion Compiler,
where they saw 35 to 40% improvements in
performance with Graviton 5.
So let's dive into some of the other
performance cases for for other use, other
workloads.
Sudhir mentioned uh machine learning,
uh, customers, customers like Sprinkler and
Mobi Eye,
and so
taking a variety of
CPU-based ML workloads and running them on
our deep learning containers
with Graviton 5, we see a 35% improvement
in performance on Pytorch.
We also have companies who run Java apps
and so we've taken a groovy Grails
app,
um,
and Grails is an open source web application framework
and
tried it on an M8G Graviton 4-ba
system and an M9G, uh, Graviton
5-based system
and here,
um, using work to to generate load
against the, the web server.
We see a 32% increase in
requests per second.
You know, one of our big focuses has been on
large workloads,
and you know, while microservices are great, there still
are monoliths in the world.
We don't have a really good open source example here, but we took
a large internal piece of code that does delivery
planning. And um
Tried that on Graviton 5 M9G
instances. Here we saw a 47%
performance increase.
Hm All right.
Um, we've also looked at Engine
X. Engine X is a popular web server. It can also
be a load balancer, and we've configured it as a load balancer
in this case,
and fixing the load generator,
fixing a set of web servers,
changing the instance in the middle from a graviton
4 or a graviton 5,
we see a 27% improvement in performance over
generation over generation. Um,
and lastly we've looked at databases and so
one we've looked at is MySQL.
We've used HammerDB
to mimic um load against
this, and Hammer DB
uh mimics a company that sells
items, keeps stock, has warehouses, receives
orders,
and measures performance and new orders per minute.
And so here too comparing a graviton
4-based M8G to a graviton 5-based
M9G,
we see a 40% improvement in performance.
Now these are the workloads that we've run.
I think the far more interesting ones are the workloads that other people
have run, and over the last couple
of weeks, a few customers have
been running on Graviton 5.
Snowflake
has
been running their virtual data warehouses on Graviton
since Graviton 2.
They recently tried an M9G instance
and found that they saw more than 30%
higher performance.
In that instance type.
Honeycomb has also been using Graviton since
Graviton 2.
They provide end to end observability software
and um
they were super excited to try
M9G.
Out of the box they saw 20 to 25%
lower latency.
And then as they kept latency
fixed and just started to crank down the
amount of CPU
they were giving the workload,
they saw 36% better throughput
for the same latency.
Airbnb has also been testing our
M9G instances,
um,
and they found they were some of the fastest
instances they've tested,
um, in, in EC2,
including 25% higher performance
than the other than the other instances
they tested.
Uh, and lastly, SAP,
uh, SAP has been running Hana Cloud
on Graviton,
and they found, uh, a, a stunning 35
to 60% performance increase in
some of the OLTP workloads
that they think are typical
of Hana Cloud, um, development.
So with this,
we have performance that varies with the workloads
we looked at between 27 and 47%
and what customers have told us,
which varies from 20% to nearly
as much as 60%.
So now I'd like to hand it over to Thibo
from Atlassian to talk about his experience
with graviton.
Thank you. Thank
you, Eli. Um, I'm Thibaud Delors,
principal engineer, uh, for Atlassian.
So in Atlassian, my main focus is cost
efficiency.
And we went through the graviton journey,
and I'm here to
explain how we went about it and
what kind of results we saw.
A bit of context of who, what
we are doing in Atlassian. So we have the Atlassian
cloud platform.
You probably know some of our products like
Jira, which is the issue tracker, confluence
for collaboration,
Bitbucket, Trello.
So all those tools are now integrated
in our cloud platform and
powered by our AI Brovo.
And on our platform we have from small
to large customer,
um, like Roblox or
um Amadeus.
Um,
and Reddit, um, and all those
customers,
they are on our platform, like I was saying, and
we are heavily relying on EC2.
So we have tens of thousands of EC2 instances,
3000 services from big
to small.
Across 15 regions
and to support 300,000
customers,
more than that actually,
and we have like a sharded infrastructure, so
that means that
for one given customer we usually
associate them
to a shard in a specific region,
um, and
they have like
They are sharing a shard with other customers,
but we have many, many shards
across the globe.
So, why did we look at graviton?
So, I'm doing cost efficiency.
One of the easiest ways to
do cost efficiency is to look at the
CPU because it can give you the
best price to
performance ratio.
We were looking at all CPU, not just Graviton,
so Intel, AMD,
Graviton,
and we were looking for like the lower
CPU utilization for the same throughput.
And also, uh, Atlassian is committed
as a commitment on the energy footprint.
So we were looking at reducing our
carbon footprint.
We have, um, so here it's like
a bit more specific to our big product,
Jira and Confluence.
We have
3,
the 3 biggest workloads that
we have is
the web servers,
the workers,
and the databases.
On the web server side, it's a
Java 17 app,
pretty big
scale on on CPU
through a scaling group.
And it's very latency sensitive,
so we really care about performances
and we don't like.
Like we, we can't have like performance
degradation from like a CPU upgrade or
something like that.
On the I think you worker side, it's a bit
more flexible as we care more about
throughput,
but it's like the same code base as the
web server, so that means that if we migrate
one, we usually migrate the other.
And its scale on queue length rather
than CPU percentage.
And we have the databases.
We are on Aurora, Progress.
We are using replicas
and usually when
we are only scaling
during like the peak hours, so 9, like
10 hours a day, we would scale
our replica, but the rest of the time
we are at just one replica.
So We have this
motto in
Atlassian which is like if you can make it happen
for Jira, you can make it happen for everything.
So we started with Jira.
Um, and the web server,
so that was really the,
the hard part of like adopting Graviton.
2 years, so that's a journey that
started like 2 years ago
and we had a failed attempt.
What we tried to do was just like migrate
from Intel to Graviton
at the time that was the latest, and that
was like beginning to be available.
And we did some tests
in our environment. We migrated
up to arm.
And it was looking good
until we went to prod.
So when we, we went to prod,
like we start, we started to see like regression,
so obviously we missed something
in our test.
And
looking at like all the flame graph and the
performances,
it was like really looking like concurrency
was the problem at the CPU level,
but we didn't know much more than that,
and we were trying to
fix the code to be more performance with graviton,
but like without much success, so we stopped the
project. And like that's basically
like 6 months of like trying to adopt
graviton that
we were like, OK, it doesn't look like
it's working for us, which is weird because
we've heard like all those stories
of like
way it works. So why doesn't it,
why it wasn't working for us was still a
mystery, but we stopped that.
Until
graviton 4.
So for graviton 4.
We were basically saying we shouldn't
repeat the same mistake.
We're going to engage AWS and
some experts to have recommendations on how
should we test
and, and what we should be doing and
making sure that we understand our regression.
So the first thing is no more micro benchmarking.
There's no point in
like just testing uh one endpoint
for latency cause
like what we noticed is that in production, that's
not what you're gonna see.
So like those signals are useless.
No passive benchmarking, which means
that during our test environment
instead of like running our
usual path test suit and looking at
the result,
we we we we will try to
be more
have like an acceptance criteria and like
clear metrics of like whether it's good or
not. And this clear metric was
throughput car braking latency.
So what we did is
Put a like do some load test on,
on the
on the web server,
see where the latency is starting
to become unacceptable and
measure the throughput at this point,
and that would give us like a good idea of like
how performance is the CPU.
And also digging into the low level of
um the,
the processor.
So ARM has um some
performance monitoring units that you can
observe and check
what is um the, the bottleneck on
the CPU.
What we found is graviton 4
basically smashed
all the results.
Like it was more, it was outperforming C6I
which was our preferred previous
instance. And also C7G
by far. And
one of the key indicators of
what was correlating with
performance was L3 cache misses.
Like we saw that the more cache misses there was,
the worse performance is, which makes
sense, but it was like really a good
reflection of
performance,
and that can be explained by
from Graviton 3 to Graviton
4.
It went from 1 megabyte
to 2 megabytes of L2 cash
and
And that was what was making the difference
here and compared to Intel,
that was the same thing like in terms of L2
and L3 cache,
Graviton had more and so
we saw like better performance.
We also see, so, um,
Like the table work, so the translation
lecoside buffer,
uh, tablework
was
reduced on Graviton 4,
which basically means that
it was using like
memory like a bit better,
and that's like really specific to
to Java, and the conclusion
of that is that we should enable
THP, which is transparent
huge pages.
And um
to try to have like
better usage of the memory
with the system.
So the result of that is
on C6I.
So compared to C6I, which was really our
baseline and what we were happy with,
Graviton 4 with THP enabled
was 32% faster.
On the other hand,
uh, graviton 3 was a bit
slower. So what was the
decision here
was that for
web server we would be using
CAG.
We always use also a fallback
stance in case there is no capacity,
and we were, uh, we decided
that that was graviton 4
as the main, um,
main CPU and C6I
as the fallback.
4.
I think workers,
it's a bit more flexible because we were not looking
at latency, we were looking at
throughput and cost efficiency
and in that instance, C7G was
the most cost efficient one.
So what we decided is still,
we're still going to try to go for Graviton
4 for
the workers but fall back to
Graviton 3
instead of Intel for the workers.
How did we roll that out?
So for the web server, when you want
to have Graviton
with Intel as a fallback,
you have to use this pattern, which is
a very well documented pattern on AWS
website, which is to use um
multi-punch, multiple launch templates
on your ASG.
So you basically need two images, one
for ARM,
one for Intel, and then you can have
like a fallback between ARM and Intel.
So that's what we had to implement for web
servers.
Uh, for async workers much simpler.
You usually in a,
in a scaling group you can have, uh, several
fallback instances without having several launch
launch, um, templates. And
so we were falling back to C7G.
Reported all of CICD
to arm.
And we deployed.
And the observed result in
production was
a throughput increase of 30%,
latency reduction of 12%, and
a cost reduction of
25%.
So 25% for
Jira in confluence that's
A lot of money.
So on this success, we decided to
Expand to the rest of Atlassian.
Actually confluence a Gan confluence databases
started like a bit earlier
and
we migrated all our instances to
graviton and it was
very smooth, very easy.
We went from R5 to R6G to
R7G to RIG,
and every time we saw a game,
like especially in R6G, which
was like the first,
the first.
The first graviton option,
um, like we saw like a big
cost reduction,
and then every time we saw better performance.
So
We have more than 3000 database
clusters in production.
They also went through PG 13
and PG 17, and every time we were
doing those upgrades, we were always comparing
like whether Graviton was still the
best option, and every time
it was the best option.
I want to
highlight that cost efficiency depends on
how, like
how you deploy your app. Like in Atlassian
we are pretty efficient
in terms of like we know when to downgrade, downsize
the database.
We know how to use red replica,
and that's why we are seeing like really
good cost savings is because we are
doing the thing.
If you are just
switching from
Some, from one instance to another
instance, but we don't,
you don't um do anything out
of that.
You don't change
your replica strategy or you don't downsize,
then you might, you might not see cost, cost benefit,
so. You have to
be efficient to make those cost savings.
We also migrated Jira, so
Jira, as I was saying,
JSM,
Confluence, and several other
products are following,
um, including our Edge,
and roughly in one year we went from
5% adoption of graviton within
Atlassian to more than 30%,
and
also I'm saving out of that.
Thanks to a collaboration with AWS
we were able to test Graviton 5,
and it's
very promising.
Um,
and
what, what we believe is the reason for such
an improvement, so the 30% throughput
improvement is as I was saying before,
L3 cache is very
related to our performance because we are a
Java shop pretty much.
And, um,
and Graviton 5 like
um increase the the L3 cache,
so.
Not so surprising, but really good
news for us, and
we are super, super excited too.
Try a graviton 5 in production.
Thank you very much.
Great. Thank you, Thibo for uh
for those great insights.
So let's uh shift gears now into talking
about some of the best practices for transitioning
to graviton and uh
what are some of the tools available to do that.
So starting with the building blocks.
Across the Linux community there's
broad support for ARM 64 out of the
box. So
whether you're using commercial distributions
or using community armies,
you can find AM 64 out of
the box Amazon machine images that's
available for you to deploy.
Using containerized workloads, there's also a lot
of good news in that space.
There's broad support for Gravidon across
all the key container areas,
so that includes Docker and Kubernetes
themselves, as well as our own AWS managed
services
such as ECS and EKS.
There's also support across multiple container
registries
um for ARM 64 in addition to multi architecture
support, so you can build container images
for X86 and ARM 64
and have the right image deployed automatically
based on the underlying architecture.
And a similar story across the DevOps landscape,
so all the popular CICD tools and
software
include support for Graviton out of the box.
So that's whether it's fully managed, self-managed,
or hybrid deployments.
So in terms of partners, so we find a lot of customers
use third party software for various
needs, be it logging software, monitoring,
security, and things like that.
So what we've done is that we've created over the
last few years a Graviton
partner program
where we worked with many of these third party ISPs
to enable support on Graviton,
and a lot of the software companies here have
tested, validated, and optimized their software.
Which then makes it really easy for customers to
discover these.
So here's a snapshot
of what we currently offer,
and since this list is rapidly changing, we
highly recommend you check the
Graviton web page for the latest and greatest.
So while you can obviously deploy your workloads
on graviton-based instances on EC 2,
We've also extended the price performance
benefits of Graviton to our various AWS
managed services.
So this gives you the most seamless path
to using graviton,
and in many cases it's simply an instance name
switch, and you're up and running,
and a lot of the heavy lifting of the architecture is
handled for you under the hood.
So all the popular services across compute,
databases, analytics,
as well as machine learning
support graviton-based instances today.
Now this is a very common question that we deal with
in a lot of customer conversations, which is around
what is the effort involved in moving to gravidon
and how should we think about that?
So here is a basic framework that we provided
as a starting point, um,
and as I said,
the most seamless way is gonna be to use a managed
service. If you're
using applications
that are, you know, interpreted languages, say
Java or No JS, PHP, Ruby,
all of those pretty seamlessly work out of the
box,
and in many cases we have many customers who
have moved that to AM 64 and gravit on very easily.
If you're using compiled languages like C, C++,
Golang, those applications
would need to be recompiled
for the ARM architecture.
But the good news here is that all the major
popular compilers will allow you to do that
really, really easily,
and we have many success stories of customers that
have moved these applications.
And finally, in the sum work high reward category
comes around applications such as .NET,
which you can modernize to Linux and
then that puts you on an accelerated path
to getting to AM 64 and Graviton as well.
So some more steps in terms of how you can start
thinking about this journey.
So the first and foremost area that I would highly
recommend is getting started with our
technical guide on GitHub.
So this really provides a lot of good
examples and use cases
broken down by applications and languages
that allows you to get the best out of the Graviton
platform and the tunings for these applications.
And secondly, you know, inventory of your software
stacks, so really understanding what OS images
you're using as a general rule,
the more current your software, the easier it
is to get adopting on Graviton.
And taking a look at those container images and
understanding dependencies and pulling the right
armies.
Unit and functional tests as part of your testing
efforts are going to be important and in some cases you might
have to write new tests like Atlassian
just described,
and we have a lot of tools over here that can actually help
you do that. So
that includes Q Developer,
AWS Transform, as well as a
new tool that we just announced earlier this
week which is AWS Transform Custom.
And finally, measuring performance, and again we have
uh some QR codes there, we have a tool called
APERF that's available for
you to profile some of your applications and really
understand where the bottlenecks are.
And we see a lot of customers deploy
on Graviton using
canary or blue-green deployments
where once you have a production traffic and you
have both clusters,
you start redirecting a small portion of that traffic
to an armed production cluster on Graviton,
and then you can turn the knob based on the
performance that you observe.
Why So
just talking more about the transform custom
that we just announced earlier in the week,
so this is a capability
where
through the modern agentic AI agent
applications, it really allows you to crush
your tech debt.
And specifically in the case of Graviton there's an
early access
program available here
for for example on Java applications
where in most cases though it works out of the box
if you're not sure about the versions
or
you need you have some native applications
coded there that are dependent on a certain language,
then this gives you a chance to identify
and modernize those very quickly.
So NetNet, here's the takeaway of all
the resources that are available.
So the first and foremost one that I would highly encourage
and recommend bookmarking is the Graviton Technical guide.
And then we also offer a free trial with
the T4G instances that gives you up to 750
hours
to jumpstart your graviton journey.
And then we have the links to both
the Que developer and the transform capabilities.
And finally, there's the graviton savings dashboard
that helps you to provide a view of
the savings that you can accrue
based on your workloads that have moved to Graviton.
that So here's
a link if you wanna try out Grabbidon 5
and MGG since that's currently in preview,
we really encourage you to sign up.
And um we really hope many
of you will get started on your graviton journey, if not
already, and it's really surprising
what customers have been able to do with just one
engineer
in one week and with one application.
So with that, I just wanna thank you for your time, making
time to attend the session today. We really appreciate
it and hope you continue to have a
great reinvent
and please do take a moment to complete the
session survey in the mobile app.
Thank you.